here we are at the Tonys again this is
old hat for you you're like shell right
no no it never gets old that we're so
fortunate to be able to make a living in
this business if you're able to get the
kind of roles that I'm so lucky to get
No and but you don't do it for any kind
of recognition you do it because it
fulfills you it empowers you to be on
stage and to be able to tell really
important funny poignant stories you've
been involved have you thought a little
bit more about me the press have you
thought about that are you like oh that
job is terrible are you like oh god they
are scary to have you has your mind
changed about me
aka the press you specifically changed
it has it changed your mind about it no
I never thought that the press was an
adversarial position and to begin with
it's a very tough job actually and if I
if I win tonight I have something that I
want to say about the press yeah so
we'll see let's talk about Aaron is
getting a movie based on Jessie for the
Breaking Bad movie will you pop up I
know you're dead but could you pop up
well rigor mortis has a way of allowing
this could be could be a flashback
flash-forward I'm still dead Walter
White I don't know I don't know you have
a beautiful voice would you ever do a
Broadway musical it is one of those
things that scares the bejesus out of me
and that's what I need to do there was a
there was a phrase that I'm that really
clicked in my head by the Alexander
Technique right says if you keep doing
what you know you'll never be able to do
what you don't know
or paraphrasing it but that's and it's
to say go ahead walk into something that
you're not familiar with and try
something new so I think maybe next year
Prada